about 100 years ago people got sick of  doing math by hand in 1936 a guy named  alan turing came up with a concept he  called an automatic machine imagine an  infinitely long piece of tape then  divided up into cells that can hold a  one or zero that tape runs through a  machine that can read or write the data  in one cell at a time a machine like  this can support loops and conditional  branching which in theory is all you  need to build any app or solve any  computational problem as long as you  have enough memory that is you would be  considered turing complete if you can  simulate this machine all modern  programming languages make the cut but  your pocket calculator does not and i  apologize if this offends anybody but  html combined with css does